yeah you shaved your facial hair yeah we
all did yeah we all did for the charity
stream that we just finished we're gonna
be like oh my god this episode so they
recorded this so long ago yeah yeah
we're really really dating ourselves
yeah we just recorded the charity stream
yeah which was for you guys was like a
month ago yeah yeah for us it was two
days ago it's a month and a half ago
right yeah more than that yeah yeah
we're trying to we're trying to get
ahead before we fly off once again
but uh yeah if you guys didn't know
about it we just finished a 24-hour
charity stream for doctors without
borders and it was extremely successful
yeah i was very surprised we raised a
hundred and seventy-six but we haven't
added the amount 180 i think about 180
adding everything that we collected in
total
uh which is absolutely [ __ ] nuts i'd
like i don't know what we expected out
of this charity stream
i was i was there was a part of me when
we were deciding okay what are we gonna
make our goal and someone was like
hundred thousand i was like
and 24 that's a lot of money yeah yeah
yeah like maybe if we were like doing a
week-long subathon yeah or something
like that because i don't know i
i only did one charity stream once like
years and years ago with archie and like
we did not raise nearly that much money
so i think in the back of my head i had
that as my benchmark yeah so when i
heard a hundred thousand i was like dude
we're not [ __ ] pewdiepie or like
jacksepticeye we're not right we're not
gonna hit those numbers right turns out
we kind of did because we were we were
like number one on twitch for like that
night
yeah yeah i'm not i think we peaked uh
53 000 viewers which is insane
um yeah personal best person
that's definitely the most i've i've
been able to it's definitely the most
i've had yeah definitely by far well i'm
not even a streamer so that's
definitely the most i've been a part of
it's just ridiculous but uh how was the
experience for you boys how
oh you know what even though i went into
it with like zero sleep it was probably
the most fun stream i've ever played
yeah yeah
i would absolutely do that again
part of me is just like i would
absolutely do that again in part not
anytime soon yeah part of me is just
like man i remember those last six hours
that was yeah i'll do it again once i
forget about how hard the last year yeah
i'm like yeah this is fine
i mean at least you at least i had you
guys and like chris and like mouse there
because like if i had done it by myself
i would not have lasted like 10 hours no
like i i was i remember the last two
three hours i was just running on
complete autopilot you know you know
when you're just using like the part of
your brain that isn't even thinking it's
just like habits you've built up that
was just me i was just like i saw bits
and pieces of the board where you're
just like you alone on the couch and
you're just like
thank you for the 20 donation
it kind of got to a point where i was
just like questioning my own insanity
like like because it was just sanity
sanity yeah understand it
crushing my own sanity questioning my
own sanity my favorite clip though is
where you like you guys where you two
were on the couch and you just started
going lords oh
and they got in the most unenthusiastic
way goes get hyped guys
[Music]
it's like the most not hype get hyped
guys i've ever heard it just it just had
such like house party vibe just like
when you stay up too late and that
there's one that one guy that just
wouldn't leave yeah yeah that was that
was like that was exactly what it felt
like where i'm just like i need to go to
bed is that one guy who doesn't know
yeah you are
you are like at every [ __ ] like all
night karaoke god is the last guy i mean
i mean i was the last guy in the stream
as well i'm just like you guys you boys
uh i mean not this wasn't a competition
obviously obviously but i i was the only
one to stay awake
right if it was conor that was in your
position he would have been like weak
you're all weak i won that competition
it was me
i carried
i think i think cause uh because i knew
you guys were there and i was like so i
can sleep then i was like yes i will
yeah but i think if it was just me alone
i would have had to i mean i would have
just oh yeah
of course and just been more miserable
yeah i mean i mean like the reason i
didn't sleep was because i knew as soon
as i closed my eyes they were not like
going they were i could not go to sleep
and come back up to like stream again
yeah that wasn't stopped yawning
i just i just walked horrible like i i
remember the last 30 minutes when i came
back i looked half dead yeah and i was
like oh good oh god
i think i used all my energy holding in
the laughs
so much energy not saying anything
during like the try not to laugh
segments yeah uh that took a lot more
energy than i thought it did it actually
took more energy than uh doing the quiz
talking or just like hanging out also
not to mention that i think we like
greatly overestimated how much energy we
were going to have because uh we had
like a schedule like a preemptive
schedule that staff made and we probably
did maybe 40 of what was originally
scheduled yeah i mean it was it was it
was a it was a few things because
obviously chris was scheduled for two
hours yeah stayed for six hours which
i'm not i'm not complaining
he was obviously having fun yeah uh but
then we also had like a bunch of a bunch
of things that we were meant to be doing
with iron mouse but by the time chris
left and mouse came on it was just we
were so out of energy that was like we
can only manage talking right now yeah
definitely how uh how did you guys
manage to recover afterwards did you
recover easily i mean recover is a
strong word i i went home and like
weirdly enough i think because i was
kind of like
reliving the moment when i was on the
train ride home so by the time i got
home i was like wide awake for some
reason and then i i was doing a little
bit of work and then my body was just
like i don't think so
and i just [ __ ] i literally passed out
on my desk
for like an hour
okay i need to go to bed
and then i slept for like 14 hours i
think oh my god and then i just
completely [ __ ] my sleep schedule for
the next day yeah i don't know like from
like my body's so weird after an
all-nighter i hate her i absolutely
[ __ ] hate it because like um during
the stream i'm like i'm gonna i'm going
to pass out as as it's well documented
that uh how close we were to passing out
yeah and uh so i remember
uh the stream finishes i do not even
remember saying like goodbye to anyone
in the office even though i know we were
just like hey congratulations
see you on see you on tuesday see you in
like two days or whatever i i think i
said see you on tuesday but i think i
just left as well i don't know if i've
it
seemed like i was rude or something i
just i need to go to my brood yeah and
remember like i remember like going to
my bed being like finally i've stayed up
all night for this didn't nap didn't
sleep i'm going to finally go to sleep
go on my bed and my body's just like
nope you don't you don't sleep now you
stay you stay awake you don't you don't
need sleep it is sunshine
how long do you stay awake i stay i stay
up for like an extra like
it took me three hours to get to a point
where i could sleep and then i slept for
three pm four p.m yeah yeah i was around
where i apologize i slept for two hours
so i was just
my day was like just [ __ ] when did you
go to bed bed then um like two in the
morning oh my god but then i did sleep
for like 16 hours so that's right so you
work at like 4 p.m the next day yeah oh
my god go on that's why i like i i woke
up when i i woke up to like connor
stream jump king i was just like [ __ ]
how are these boys like awake and
streaming right now i'm like fighting
for my life
sunday i went home and then i had like
three hours sleep and then i went out
for some drinks and a meal how the [ __ ]
i was like fine how how
i got tired around
10 p.m so i went home and then i slept
woke up early and played jump king but i
finished it you finished it yeah you
both finished it right i finally
finished babe with the ascension yeah
it's just like the worst thing ever i
don't ever want to do it ever again
finally finished the base game that was
uh yeah when are you gonna do the dlc
joy
you know you know what sucks like at the
end of that stream i was like you can't
pay me to play the dlc i want my
happiness back in my life but then the
moment i turned off the stream i was
like [ __ ] i can't want to keep playing
yeah because you're like you're like but
there's more yeah because because it was
it was the fact that there was so much
encouragement online when i posted my
time and people were like dude you're
actually cracked and i was like
give give me a little more prank
the game has a way of humbling you
because i thought the same thing when i
did like the third dlc i was like i'm
correct dude i'll be able to do this new
one like yeah yeah i was like i was
actually like worried i was like what if
i like beat this dlc too fast too fast
and it's like not a good stream yeah
yeah yeah and then like the first eight
hours of playing it i was like oh no
oh no this is hard this is really hard
and it took me 48 hours
to beat the dlc the fan made dlc but now
i know what it feels like to be an alpha
gamer yeah and now i can finally say hey
god when are you finishing john
king i will i'll do it again
i [ __ ] feel like you know [ __ ]
that scene in [ __ ] my hero academia
where like all my is just pointing at
you so it's your turn now it's your turn
oh
i'm just here watching on tv i'm not
even like involved and here you are
pointing at me being like it's your turn
you've done half of it so you have to do
the other one it's a half of it is it
half of it uh gone gone to maybe like
forty percent yeah i gotta go where did
you get to i can't remember he got to
the [ __ ] uh
after the no he got not even there like
before that the the town in the sky
bargain that's it
i mean i will finish here just because i
i knew it's like one thing when i
started it and i was just like it's i i
have the same inkling feeling in me
where i just doesn't it doesn't feel
comfortable until i'm i finish it take
your time
yeah yeah it's been a few weeks since
you last but you're gonna get rusty
you'll start with zero again i'll be
fine i'll be fine i'll be uh i will be
like pure muscle yeah it'd be like you
never left it's gonna be like dementia
the game with guys every time he goes
back to he's like oh i gotta learn this
section again
it'll be like 30 if uh like my
playthrough would be like 50 hours or
something spread
if anything you now have someone else to
compare yourself to and that's mainly
because she also started it as well oh
my god and uh that stream last night was
hilarious
as well yeah
jesus christ it's like a virus but don't
worry if you if you thought look like
meleen just got to the bottom of the
sewers and it took her like a couple of
hours to get there so i just think it's
like the one of the best games to stream
it's just so it's so intuitive there's
no explanation needed yeah you know like
some games it's like power ups level ups
you know and then there's like oh you
can unlock this thing and then
everyone's like oh what's going on but
jump king is literally just
you can one mechanic jump one button you
understand immediately from watching
that they're trying to go up and when
they fall you're like oh i get it this
is fun to watch it's also just a pretty
game
it's good it's a really pretty game yeah
i love the aesthetic you know i i will
say you know i thought you were
bullshitting when
you said oh you know it's just a fun
game it's a fun game but no it is i do
actually genuinely think it's a fun game
there's a high that you get when you've
reached like
your new personal best yeah you know
what i mean you're like damn you're like
this is a good feeling and then that
lasts for like three seconds before you
like fall for the first time
i know we spoke about jumping so much on
this podcast now it's just like taking
over my life but uh on the first map
there's like a very solid checkpoint
when you get to that you feel like i can
do this the 70 one right yeah yeah when
you get to the the church the church
yeah and then you're like oh my god i
can do this yeah that's when it feels
good yeah that's when i was like all
right i got this you got this key yeah
yeah you can do it then if you can get
that you can do it easily so uh dlc for
me is a hard maybe then you should do it
i think i think i want to like maybe
put in a couple of like other games that
i've been wanting to play hard maybe
what does that even mean
were you like being like joey won't ever
commit to anything no maybe he's about
the best you can get yeah
i mean you know it's better than arcane
yeah we'll fly out
i am committed to my neutrality here it
could be yes it could be the problem do
you want to marry the bride
maybe
that's a hard baby
that's a hard baby my ass is firmly
planted on the fence like
what was yours your viewership higher
than normal when you were doing jump
king oh yeah yeah for sure for sure but
you know it's like what do i what do i
prioritize a clout or happiness
it's a hard choice for every youtuber
you can have both
i'm just waiting for when the kirby game
comes out dude that's when that's real
happy i play games now like when i'm
playing like when i play pokemon artists
i'm like there's just not enough
challenge
even though there was there literally
was like there definitely was but the
thing was is that i never once thought
for a moment i wasn't going to be able
to do it whereas jump king has that
thing where it's like i don't know if
you can do it man wait but you did the
you did that last fight yeah yeah yeah
yeah and you struggled a lot with it i
did but like at no point did i ever feel
like this is too hard really yeah
because like to me like that was easily
the hardest in-game pokemon fight it is
it is even then i like there's no point
by doing it where i'm like i don't know
if i can do this yeah i don't think like
i just felt like i just got to grind a
little bit more i don't know man
was hard as [ __ ] okay yeah yeah i want
to see you where's like new babe plus
when i was playing that game with jump
king's the second map yeah there was
like the i i did it over three streams
so one on stream second stream third
stream
the the second stream after it and i
went to bed yeah i had like anxiety i
was like i was like what if i just like
can't do it stay calm what if i can't do
it yeah like i'm never gonna be able to
forget this if i can't do it
and then i woke up the next day stage
bossed it just destroyed it right right
wow
damn i think you have an addiction i do
yeah
there's definitely an addiction because
you know
there's been like uh i kind of got out
of like um multiplayer games that was
kind of where i got the kick from
beating other people you know there's a
hard ceiling in multiplayer games where
you're like if i want to be able to
improve at this game i have to put an
absurd amount of hours in right yeah
consistently yeah wait but is is 45
hours in one jump king map not only time
[Music]
an fps first person shooter multiplayer
game whatever yeah 45 hours is nothing
that's true that's absolutely nothing
you're competing against people who do
45 hours a week yeah how many hours have
you put us into all of jump king right
now uh 100 something that's that's
that's quite a lot yeah that's the
persona yeah that's a percentage
throughout the apex i have like over a
thousand probably yeah that's true like
it's and even then like i'm i'm just
like uh i got to master once and that
was that was like that was me going
insane right well why don't you get into
more like challenging games then because
you you said you don't really play like
the souls types games or like i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna do algebra but like
i feel like that's it's a different type
of challenge because we're jumping it's
just like one mechanic that you have to
like milestone and master whereas with
something like elden ring or sifu it's
like a lot of things going on at once
you know there's a lot of different
approaches a lot of ways to master the
game yeah yeah i just like jumping
because there's no like there's no
[ __ ] there's like if you [ __ ] up
absolutely nothing there's no other
facts single factor yeah because with
games like dark souls or like seafood
yeah it's like it's like you can blame
it on like the enemy like [ __ ] that one
frame hit me yeah yeah yeah yeah i i
know i'll make up excuse me there's no
enemies to get in your way it's just
it's just you you're in the way of
yourself you are your own enemy yeah
yeah exactly
almost like [ __ ]
don't trust anyone not even yourself
i mean like the each dlc gets more
brutal though like on you know the first
jumping you can only fall like two
screens max that's what i'm dreading man
and i felt like 20. what if i like
actually start raging
i do but i don't i don't want that
though i don't want to get angry not
like an actual angry though like a like
an angry video game angry
it's a different kind of anger i don't
know how to explain it it's an anger
where you're like
you shout but it it doesn't actually
like actually get you upset right kind
of like ah
all right back to you
this is it's just like a slight
frustration slight annoyance
it's stabbing your toe
well no there's there's there's
different
kinds of video games
i don't
not like a 13 year old on xbox live
anger where i just test out all the new
bad words i've learned right yeah that
kind of anger like you know like a
mild frustration like when the website
when you fill out the whole form and
then it reloads for some reason you're
like
oh yeah yeah and then you like really
that's that's the anger you feel dude
when when you should have have you not
had that i get so angry when that
happens that's like you've like filled
out a whole sign up form put the credit
card info in the address in all the
right space you're about to go to the
checkout for some reason times out for
some of your times out or it reloads
you're like
like [ __ ] guts theme goes through my
head yeah is it even worth signing up
again i don't know i don't know if this
is worth it anymore i don't even want
the trampoline yeah
the worst part is when you fill out
everything correctly except for that one
field but the website's designed in a
way that when you press send it it goes
uh this one field is incorrect we've
reset the whole
[Applause]
like imagine that happens but just it
happens to every website you sign up
that's that's like there's so many
japanese websites every japanese website
dude like i don't know if japanese
people are aware of ux designers yeah
they certainly it's just like the amount
of times i've been like [ __ ] cucked
by not using like half width yeah
this is the my [ __ ] god
this is the biggest joke in japan and
like it's something you'll never
experience unless you've either tried to
buy stuff
like on the japanese website but for
some reason they have full width and
half with katakana and
can you explain that by the way what is
the point of full width and half i'll
tell you exactly the difference okay
there is none
that's what's so frustrating about it
someone explained it to me one time had
something to do with how they coded way
back the initial internet oh yeah in
japan and it was like a layover from
that essentially that they're probably
using and they never like decided to
sort out yeah but i mean like i've told
the story of how i interned for an iit
company and i had to fix a bunch of like
clients websites and i had to go like
through the html and i had like almost
had a stroke looking at some of these
codes because it's like oh my god you
said you built this website last year
you're using code literally from the 90s
i was like what of course this like of
course this page takes like 20 seconds
to load even though it's just text based
because it's so much [ __ ] code here
because [ __ ] uh it's so weird because
there's so much like convenience stuff
and stuff crazy stuff you can do that
you can't do in other countries yeah and
then they're like how about websites we
just we just keep them [ __ ] you just
keep weirdly enough the best designed
websites are the [ __ ] anime trailer
websites
right yeah the ones that are like they
use like [ __ ] like pretty like java
and like css it's like oh that looks
fancy yeah like when that website was
like when the last bucket like
monogatari uh volume was coming out yeah
just like scrolling down for the entire
history yeah of uh of the series i was
like damn this is a beautiful looking
website oh my god someone an actual
coder yeah and that's a programmer made
this dude can you not add this to your
ui design when i'm trying to [ __ ] buy
something exactly sign up to a site like
rockton is just like a hell hole of a
website because you don't know you go to
like because like on amazon for example
amazon's so good there yeah they don't
do this because on amazon it's like okay
there's the [ __ ] picture of the thing
you want to buy there's how many is left
when it's gonna arrive here's all the
information everything is perfectly laid
out with every single item yeah
meanwhile with roktan it's just a
[ __ ] free-fall it's like would you
like 17 banners that have nothing to do
with the product you're actually buying
by the way where is the purchase button
oh it's buried deep beneath this [ __ ]
wall of text and every time i go on a
rock date it's so handy because you get
so much stuff on rockton that you can't
get on amazon yeah but it's a [ __ ]
it's just a struggle to try and like buy
anything because it doesn't even tell
you when it arrives i don't know that's
that's not the final boss the final boss
is yahoo
oh my god where you you can't even like
immediately you can't even sign up with
an account that you want you need like a
special you need a special yahoo account
yeah uh so you need to just sign up to
yahoo and it just it's not your normal
yahoo it's japanese yahoo as well i have
a yahoo email account something like
duncan or something i don't know if they
chose the name for me it's really weird
of course it's a yahoo japan account
because no one outside of japan you just
[ __ ]
me
so you need to sign up with a special
yahoo account to sign up to this uh
yahoo auctions account to then just not
even like
i don't even know what the etiquette is
in terms of like bidding stuff and how
to do it i've dead ass never even used
yahoo auctions just because i refuse to
make a yahoo because i i i i have a bad
rating on it because i forgot one time
to say i got the thing oh yeah yeah i
got it i got that on miracare
angry message from a dude who was like
why haven't you told me that you got it
this has been an awful experience for me
i'm like
i just figured if i didn't say anything
that means like i got it yeah right
you'd think so but like how did you how
did you pay can you pay with like credit
card or something yeah so it's really
confusing because there's like when you
auto translate it in google there's like
online pay and like something else that
sounds like online pay yeah yeah and i
remember that i was confused and i click
one of them and then i had through this
whole weird kind of thing with my bank
where i had to then like contact my bank
to do the online payment oh my god where
there was just another field that just
let you put your credit card information
in and it isn't clear it wasn't it
didn't say like credit card it said
something else yeah really annoying
really really annoying i hate using it
don't bother that's what i mean like as
well a lot of the websites that offer
english they're like okay you click
english send you to a brand new website
that doesn't have half the [ __ ] the jam
yeah yeah yeah whereas like amazon it's
like you change to english nothing
changes except language